hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John Humphrey holding got Torrio's
guys we're gonna watch what I'm assuming
is the most positive episode of this
season a game of Thrones and just a
minute here but right before we do that
I want to say thank you to Eric over at
nerd cronic for editing this video you
guys can follow him on social media this
man has done work for many people
including OCH assad iman snow and even a
lot of work on the Schmo down you guys
can go check out his youtube channel and
in his podcast whatever podcasts are
actually found just to reiterate we can
only show about ten minutes of footage
during our reaction that is just the
fair use rules doesn't mean the videos
monetize it just means you guys get to
watch it but if you want to stream along
with us for a full-length uncut reaction
you guys can head over to our patreon
page over there we do weekly Q&A s as
well as TV show reaction stream along
for many shows that includes my hero
academia attack on titan and i got to
continue that this week one punch man
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood Gotham
John did all panting of Hill House and
supernatural several of those shows
actually have reaction highlights
included those are supernatural one
punch man Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood and my hero academia of
course Game of Thrones is included over
there as well also I know two people in
my life that whenever animals die on
screen it pisses off their souls very
much Andrew Gordon and Olivia I know she
is not alone so there's some animal
deaths and you get upset she has every
right to yeah I'm gonna scream I'm real
yeah I know like but deal with it deal
with deal with it anywho let's get to
this
oh no I'm sorry
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it'll miss us bunches so be a signal to
ladies that's cool we're gonna win
everyone's gonna be fine
Wow Wow can she do that for everyone
[Music]
sniffles realizes oh wow dude the budget
oh my god but they just all got wiped
out holy [ __ ]
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so hard to feel hope
start fighting fighting just went to
[ __ ] like right away right like evil did
it an army of Darkness was like an
actual gritty horse
[Applause]
[Music]
need a little bit before gets terrible
again have some dialogue I want to
appreciate the beauty of the war
choreography and the shots but I'm like
so [ __ ] terrified
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
strangely comforting that's very
understanding
[Music]
oh damn they're all gonna start just
going for it aren't they
yup there it is
[Music]
know that it yes
yes how the [ __ ] can they possibly win
how can they possibly beat when this I
just don't understand there's no way
[Applause]
yeah man
ya know you stab that dude right the
face she's sacrificed yourself man dude
sacrifice yourself
[Music]
[Music]
you guys need to start strategizing some
[ __ ] man
and yes they need like [ __ ] stretch
that's something oh [ __ ] that scene in
the trailer
oh you're like breathing heavy up
against the wall
Aria is so far the best part of this
whole episode yeah ghost running
[Music]
don't know
[Music]
[Music]
set up shop many eyes forever you're
right about that brown eyes green eyes
blue eyes blue eyes
I briefly one thing one thing fall back
[Music]
well to be
[Applause]
[Music]
that means the lago writing boys yup for
so good
that'll be awesome the night changes
diapers
she to it
just like don't want to celebrate yeah
you don't want to stop oh my god
oh no no no no no oh no oh dick move man
the only shot as John has to kill him
like their only shot such a deal with
the Crips called it dead or rising I
didn't I was half hoping he couldn't do
if they've been dead for a long time why
go up in the sky
oh my god no okay
who's that
Jolly's don't you'll just become one of
them no fight
[Music]
Oh daddy look at kicking sometimes
you're a good man
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so I got the microphone there god no
Jorah no someone get him a doctor
no please
No
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
yep I think I want to clap for that
episode they work your asses off [ __ ]
Anessa 80-minute movie there and oh boy
oh boy
alright let's talk about all right so
we'll talk about everyone who died in a
minute but no got dusted but damn damn
dude
they delivered on what they said in
terms of wanting to make like a cinema
level scope of it yeah I'm not sure I
drank this battle in terms of all the
awesome battle scenes as it had in Game
of Thrones but in terms of like portrait
likes images you know his sequences like
when they're flying in the sky are a lot
of these angles look like we were
watching like a painting in action can
the moment it's so scary and terrifying
and it's hard to just admire and
appreciate the beauty of so many of
these shots cuz I'm so in the moment but
you know like ever looking back there's
a lot of like very beautiful haunting
imagery throughout here that they really
did up their a-game you're like okay
this is what that whole budget talk is
all about yeah that as well as all the
stuff inside like even though it's not
as you know heavy effects it's still
like the tangible sets there and when
they're indoors like in these actual
different narrow hallways and passages
it feels like they really went the extra
mile to have a very tangible set on hand
so it feels real like they really put
you in the shoes of everybody in that
like throughout the episode I just kept
thinking to myself how horrifying it
would be to be somebody participating in
this battle yeah because everything
around you is such a nightmare a little
dark at some times I couldn't really see
it was just mass chaos but I think
that's kind of what they were going for
that was overall theme was just
everyone's being taken out it's just
mass chaos at this point the scenes in
the sky with the Dragons it was
beautifully shot so I thought it was
wonderfully done episode yeah and also
the music I love the sound design when
there wasn't music you know really
feeling that cold environment but also
with the music there's like a mixture of
that menacing Terminator to music with
some like hans zimmer s like score I was
a a constant percussion yeah and I was
even thinking of others this like album
I listened to a long time ago which is
all those kind of me instrumental music
hair take my lust mordioux vibe here was
like we were saying feeling very
realistic you know like you hear big
battle secrets and this is what you're
gonna be building up for that was for
some reason expecting like oh I'm sure
is gonna be really harrowing and sad or
whatever but I was expecting I don't
know if the right words
glamorous-looking
episode well but it felt so gritty that
I was like this is giving me anxiety and
I have a headache because this feels but
I know there's like the whites and then
there's dragons but it also feels like
I'm watching something very real and so
it was really hard to sit through at
times yeah it has that Lord of the Rings
II sort of epic yeah very tangible Quinn
and a more real r-rated version of that
yeah well I think I know some people
complained that the previous season was
a little bit blockbuster II at times and
so I can see why you might expect for
this to be a little more glamorized but
yeah I loved about this whole episode
that they honed in on the realism and
the horror and yet what if he was like
on our side yeah yeah so many we're
gonna see a lot yeah yeah and I love the
hunting quality because it is so natural
it's just because they're forces are so
awe-inspiring Lee Tara pulling yeah and
they really captured that with you know
the Dragons with the Giants with just
the way they they really showed the
hordes just overpowering everyone or
that shot where the line of flaming
swords that goes out like they're really
great at communicating visually just the
nightmare that this all is for left and
right you're like who's gonna die who's
gonna die and I think I think we counted
like six main deaths at least something
like that I mean the first big one was
Edie that was one that like you'd see
coming in the moment I was like a
generic war/battle death really like you
saved so we'll pick them up you look at
each other for a while that's why I was
like keep fighting keep fighting yeah
that beat is all yeah yeah cuz it was a
I believe so it was like the 999 so and
then you know he brought the Giants
Lyanna Mormont I thought they're like oh
my god we gonna crush this little girl
we're just gonna have this like super
gruesome death but it was cool that she
was able to have like one of those
rewarding deaths where she's second it
feels like everyone who died died doing
in a sacrificial manner you know
everybody died you know giving their
life for something or giving yeah taking
that one last opportunity to make a
difference in the battle and yeah
everybody gets a moment to truly shine
and and maybe even get an arc wrapped up
before they go I think last week we all
said that Theon would probably die this
episode I thought it was really
beautiful the way they handled his death
this whole time he's been wanting you
know Redemption even though he said I'm
gonna like you know defend you brand
because of everything I did I was a
[ __ ] up last time I was there having
that moment with bran to say you're a
good man Theon thank you like just
letting him know look you're gonna die
right now but I want you to know that I
forgive you and you've you've redeemed
yourself yeah and such a touching moment
and in the back of my mind I'm like I
wonder if Rey I knew exactly how this
would play out so that entire moment
he's waiting for aria she's Doctor
Strange even the suns arterian scenes
all the dialogue scenes they were
important moments in the important dials
or planets to have even salsa and Tyrion
it seemed like they were hinting or
teasing out something I'm like well into
in that moment to me it felt like that
they thought that we were gonna dice and
this is and all they have is each other
not like they like you know one for the
lips or something like that but it's but
still is that thing where you're like I
heard they just had a full-on sex scene
and then cut it out because they're like
this isn't and then you know you got
barrack in here - that was heroin in
that moment you mean you were calling it
the whole time
yeah probably heroes this is so I but I
was like it's more than like yeah it's
because if I forgot why why you need or
something specific you know because of
the mountain
I knew that down had to survive because
we have to have the brothers showdown
between the mountain and the hound and
Bear died forever ago in the books so it
was just a matter of time but that was
cool though to wrap it back over
Melisandre also saying the bards kept
you around for a reason brought you
yeah so does that mean that the gods are
just the producers of the show yes but I
love the way they realized that and the
way he like you know makes the extra
effort to like really barricade yeah
that part of the hallway and I really
hold them back for any big depth
sequences you need at least one moment
that feels christ-like in the hallway
yeah that's better than laying down one
place like uses him as a shield even I
mean he's pretty much basically dead but
at one point she uses his body as a
shield number one that's what he would
want but still it's so weird to make
that happen yourself yeah I do feel that
for George or has always been one of my
favorite characters than that and I do
feel that I mean if he's gonna go out
you even want to die protecting this the
woman he loves yeah I didn't disagree
with the way any of the deaths went down
they all felt appropriate and they felt
in tune with how this character deserves
to go out yeah there wasn't just some
surprise death yeah to the degree of
just like did it see that coming and now
yeah that's not fair and I thought nice
the way they capped the episode off with
Melisandre kind of walking out into the
morning and laying down and fading away
might have wanted their revenge and she
deserved to die by their hands but she
really served her purpose
and did a lot to help oh yeah in this
battle bringing Jon Snow back in general
so I feel like she deserved to go out on
her own terms funny enough I felt like
Jon Snow participated the least in a lot
of this that's like I know in the
beginning it is an epic episode in the
beginning of it you know there's a
little bit of a delayed reaction for the
Dragons to enter yeah there's a part
where like what they're so high up worth
yeah they put them in an interesting
obstacle with having to deal with you
know the night king storm mutant power
affected to be able to control the
weather they were just like trapped in
there and I thought that was kind of
clever to actually have them trapped in
this snowstorm in a sky
just can't see past anything even when
they were trying to make fire they can't
see the signal there's no way they can
see the signal room and probably don't
even know where they're at I think we
all thought that was gonna be like John
Stowe is gonna have a showdown with a
night king but to me Arya was throughout
this whole episode the highlight for me
yeah
when she's up there like doing all the
spear fighting skills and yeah it is so
awesome and then even getting that real
horror movie element where she's having
to sneak around and she doesn't know how
many are there they really love the way
they choreographed that whole sequence
because you think okay there's two heart
there's three there's the book oh
there's a lot more even though that's
it's probably the most relieving part of
the scene it still is like oh god oh
yeah didn't know you're like I wonder if
she's not just fighting these few you
know yeah exactly because there's a lot
more than the second you think she gets
away that she's having to find her way
through the hallway and also I think one
major thing they enhanced in terms a
relationship and story lines between the
hound and Arya because they did have a
little moment where Arya saves the
hounds life the Hound is terrified and
but he like decides to continue fighting
when he sees arias in danger through
visual storytelling we've got in there
and some of them having a dialogue where
we're like we actually like each other
and we're looking out for each other
you're all right yeah they're like no
but they do care about one another and
it was like a good way to solidify that
through oh yes type of nightmarish
sequence that we got for an hour and
something some odd minutes
I really thought like we were gonna lose
like brienna times or the episode was so
chaotic and the way it was shot that I'm
like did we'd miss I feel like if there
was a major death we would have like
really you know let it settle in right
we would have had that because there was
a time where look like Gilly might have
died there wasn't like at the top of the
episode of but yeah and they're getting
the crypts I thought she maybe got
dragged away or something but like early
on in the episode when the night Kings
you know forces like they first set in I
thought just like everyone was gonna go
right away I love that that gave us
opportunities at least to show also like
Jamie jumping in to help Brianna Brinn
returning the favor of helping Jame
right you know like the Dothraki got
taken out there but Jorah was with the
doll tracking so his ghost we see Jorah
returned but we don't see ghosts
returned but we also don't see ghosts
rise back up again when the night came I
think when they started charging I think
ghost turn to the left I think I did
yeah I think ghosts gonna show up with
all the other direwolves didn't know
about and they're gonna march on King's
okay I think ghost got very distracted
from the very beginning of this battle
they did a great job at setting up that
wherever there's hope you're gonna lose
your hope and like you just kept going
that way Oh Melisandre shows the light
the Trinity all good already source yeah
we're gonna be good if Dothraki go in
and it's totally you don't even see what
happens this oh no they're all gone even
when they do light you have the trench
and then they start sacrificing
themselves to get on there
it was so sinister and it's so just yet
it's like it really feels like pure evil
I thought fairies were supposed to let
part of Melisandre prophesy I mean we
don't know why yeah 50 years from now
another prophecy there is a big moment
here we're having a Daenerys did take a
long time to start flying like show I
don't know why she was I don't know why
she was just I mean maybe you guys have
an idea why but I'm in the moment of us
watching it I'm like why is she just on
the ground why she's not flying away
John the worst just why you and leave
you here after you fall goodbye I would
stood out to me was I thought we would
have a moment where she has she's gonna
like potentially allege John but it
seemed like the second she I mean we
didn't see her point of view but she
definitely just helped saved his ass
like no questions asked him was and went
down there to go help him oh yeah and it
seemed like the last thing on her mind
was the Iron Throne and just keeping him
alive well yeah I think the devastation
of the battle and seeing what the forces
were capable I like that was the the
impression that the very first wave you
know how non effective the infantry was
just like really is a great visual
communicator like okay nothing matters
this is gonna in
consume the world if we all don't act
right now like I think that is a great
just way of communicating that you know
she dresses in the previous episode
maybe Jon Snow manipulated me to come
here and fight for his cause and now she
can see beyond any shadow of any doubt
that this cause is the cause you know
and I think our reaction are you saving
the day is plenty because you don't see
that coming
you're like oh no she could've died in
the second she kills him that was her
reflexes are the best cuz you don't know
what's gonna have I am when they were
going in slow motion and playing that
awesome music but I was thinking about
all the bastards I'm like I remember we
had something similar right where we
thought they'd always lost but
something's had somebody has to happen
right so I was thinking uh something has
to happen but even when she showed up
and you get the cats I'm like oh never
mind it's not gonna want but damn what a
great gray moment I don't know how she
got so high it looked like someone threw
her yeah I don't know what happened to
me it's kind of like not about the logic
of that moment yeah it's more emotional
impact of that moment and who re has
become yeah I'm very forgiving of the
logistics I don't know how exactly she
got there but she got there yeah and
part of who re has become as somebody
who is you know of an order who can
sneak around in ways really how do they
get there without anybody the thing
about the sneaking though you got a
whole crowd of ain't over there exactly
I don't know from above big like of all
the characters she's the only like small
masterson yeah so in that sense I guess
if anybody's gonna barter is like
whatever is my logic for the whatever I
guess now that we got that out of the
way we got a couple things to really
hone in on Game of Thrones political
wise Cersei what's gonna become of the
Iron Throne now that Daenerys Daenerys
and John do have to work that out find
anyone to fight now yes rocky are all
gone I'm solid are pretty much are
pretty depleted yeah very least oh
that's gonna the battle for the iron
throne is gonna be a key and nasty a how
are you supposed to get another
crazy battle I think episode 5 is
another crazy babble there's got to be
another crazy I read you something about
the lighting at the new apartments maybe
that'll be like a totally daytime like
really bright bad probably did actually
that could be in the deck yeah what do
you think of this episode of Game of
Thrones and I would like to give a page
from the day shadow to a man named JN
Valenti
have I ever told you about JM Valente
jamb Valente has been a long time like
one of our earliest pages he is the most
fun person to engage with in
conversation because you'll send him a
message maybee asking him a question or
two
you won't hear from him for months
they'll say pledged then suddenly he
sent you a monologue of what I could
only describe as a stream of
consciousness is journaling session yeah
where I'm like I don't know if he
answered anything of what I said and I'm
not sure what he's talking about I've
looked over at you but I'm gonna do my
best to reply to this he's one of my
favorite people because of how
charmingly strange you are I wouldn't
have you any other way so thank you
buddy for being you much love to you you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell thank you
John and Olivia for being you no problem
it's a nerve cronic for putting this all
together check out our full-length
stream along on patreon onto editing